this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] it's Tuesday the 3rd of
January the joint wants to introduce
mint mobile listen why are you still
paying insane amounts of money every
month for your phone bill why right now
when you switch to Mint mobile you'll
get an unlimited plan for 50 off Uncle
Joey making savings and if you order
from home and save with phone plans
starting at 15 a month Harry because
this deal ends January 15th by any three
month plan and get three more months
free even on their unlimited plan all
mint Mobile plans come with unlimited
talk text high-speed data delivered on
the nation's largest 5G Network love
your current phone no problem use your
own phone with mint Mobile plan and
switch easily in minutes with esim by
any three month mint Mobile plan and get
three more months free by going to
mintmobile.com Joey again that's
mintmobile.com Joey I'm gonna cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month with
mintmobile.com Joey offer ends January
15th so get on it the joint is also
brought to you by freeze pipe listen I
had a good time this holiday season with
freeze pipe they sent me the 2023
version holy [__]
set the [__] herb man free it's
time to invest in yourself and get the
best tools for the job freeze pipe is
here to make sure you got the best tools
to get you high all the way to 2028
that's how we're rolling just freeze it
back and rip that [__] the smoke
passes through the Frozen part cooling
down the smoke as you inhale like I said
I had a [__] Jingle Ball of a time
with freeze pipe it didn't snow but it
snowed in my lungs with freeze pipe it
cools down the Smoke by hundreds of
degrees now the freeze pipe is even
better because they've updated their
bung so you have six independent
freezing calls for even better airflow
and much easier cleaning experience your
uncle Joey's taking K on this one you
know when it comes to rifa I do only the
[__] Goods
freezepipe.com whether it's the bubbler
the bung the [__] listen get yourself
a new bong pipe a bubbler you're not
gonna be [__] sad and Uncle Joey's
gonna take okay I'm gonna give you 10
off your first order and that's the
t-h-e
freezepipe.com [__] the joint is
also brought to you by that's it you
[__] let's kick this
[__] off on a Tuesday morning
[Music]
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
joint
[Music]
foreign
what's happening you bad [__]
2023 is upon us Yayo free and 2023 you
know what I'm saying stress free and
2023. it was a great little break I
missed you [__] with all my
heart but I also need to take a break
with the family it's the holiday season
I didn't want to focus on this [__] and
what the [__] is going on in the world
so
Christmas was great I went over to the
tree you know did all simple [__] like
that went into New York City saw a rat
that's always great on [__] Christmas
that means you're gonna get a great
[__] crate on the on the ninth day of
Christmas I saw a [__] rat
went over saw the tree that was great
with the girls uh went over with some
friends at econo's
and then uh Christmas Eve uh
it was a quiet Christmas guys we went
across the street had some nice [__]
Italian food some Lobster fried Diablo
she made the best stuff [__] clams
I've ever had in my goddamn life I was
home by 11.
the gifts were great it was just a very
quiet you know break I mean you sit
there expecting all this [__] to happen
then New Year's came and the week before
New Year's I must I talked to 20 000
people and I asked them all the same
question what the [__] are you doing for
New Year's
do you know I only out of all the people
I spoke to there was one couple
Trish Florentine lady who sold me the
house that was going out to dinner at
six o'clock and I spoke to her husband
yesterday at the game Sunday and he was
telling me they were home by 7 30 and in
bed by nine this had to be the lamest
[__] New Year I mean listen guys I'm
a lame dude it's not like I'm gonna go
out and jump up and down any Quaaludes
those days a long [__] God
but at the same time I wanted to you
know I stayed up past one I watched the
honeymoon of marathon till 6 a.m I
[__] smoked dope I ate those silly
mushrooms I was [__] up and I ate some
different Edibles on New Year's Eve that
I only ate 150 milligrams they're the
sweet treats from [__] Stoner Club
The Grape Ape that 500 for the bag but
it's 50 milligrams each and The
Honeymooners were coming out I got back
from New Year's I didn't do much I went
to my buddies they made a [__]
tremendous lasagna
we watched a movie called Sea of Love
with Al Pacino and John Goodman [__]
Helen Barkman [__] tremendous I seen
it already
and then I just watched the [__]
Georgia game and uh they came back but I
didn't cover what the [__] I was given
five I should have bet the money line
and we were home by 12 15. I came home
me and my wife stood up for like an hour
talking [__] and uh I watched on him
with a marathon [__] tremendous
I found myself crying three times
throughout the night every time I
watched The Honeymooners I'm not
watching The Honeymooners
I'm revisiting my past it's like
it's the weirdest [__] thing that
night I was like going through changes
like the way Lisa I used to go through
when he used to eat Edibles and be a
different person like I was I watched
like two episodes and then I would take
through bong hits and I would drink some
water and I'd [__] and that was it I
kept testing myself on my [__] tired
but
my mind just ran away from me when I was
watching The Honeymooners that night I
was watching the one about the taxes
when he he made him a mistake on his tax
and he thought they were gonna throw him
in jail and [__] the jokes were
hysterical he went to throw Norton out
and he goes I'm throwing you out and
he's like I'm not scared of you Norton's
like [__] it Ralph says to him Norton
I'm counting the three he goes if you
could count they wouldn't be
investigating if he had taxes [__]
hysterical I just died I just died and I
laughed so hard and I just started
crying and I'm not crying because it's
that funny I've seen these and heard
these jokes 50
000 [__] times what shocks me about
when I watched Honeymooners or the
certain handful of shows like when I was
a kid I watch them and I think about I
used to watch the show my mother was
alive
and it just [__] killed that thought
right there the thought of
that 50 years later I still find this
show funny like [__] funny as [__]
and the other thing that makes me cry is
you [__] could come up with all
your stupid [__] shows and all your
stupid [__] comedies and all your
[__] with your 20 writers when you
watch The Honeymooners you watch real
comedy writing it is as brilliant as it
could come 1955 1951 he had two people
on the [__] staff and I gotta tell
you something the writing is just superb
I also watching 99 000 question
all right that is one of the greatest
written episodes
that I have ever watched on television
Ralph has to [__] uh go on a game
show to name songs and he has to name
the 99 that the you get to the 99 000
question you have to go to like the nine
dollar question and the 16 question than
the hundred dollar question you just
keep going up it's like Jeopardy same
thing
but it was about music he picks music he
was really nervous when he went to the
show the first time and then he had he
had to come back the time ran out and he
had to come back and I gave him time to
practice and [__] and the whole time
Norton was his piano player
and he was going through all these songs
The Neighbors were running songs at him
and [__]
and the next thing you know before
Norton would play every song he'd go
and sure enough we got Ralph would go
why is it that before every [__] song
you got to play that song and normally
go Dizzy Dean warms up in the bullpen I
gotta warm up so the Night Comes he gets
to the [__] he gets down there for
the first question the first one like
the hundred dollar question and before
he goes he tells the guy I just want to
let you know
that I've studied and I'm going all the
way to the 99
000 [__] answer and the guy goes well
that's great to know well here's your
first quiz he goes who is the composer
of Swanee River and Ralph is like Swanee
River and all of a sudden he goes play a
few bars from and it's that song
all the songs that he studied he never
asked Norton what the name of that song
was that's how he and he goes at the end
he goes who is the composer and he goes
Ed Norton because he just couldn't
[__] guys that is the best episode
well written episode I have ever [__]
and I cry I just cry like a little [__]
but anyway who gives a [__] about the
honeymoon
[__] Wednesday night
I was very lucky listen for all that
going on guys when it comes to stand-up
comic I really have nothing going on I
could lie to you guys and tell you that
I'm killing it and all this [__] listen
I'm working with new material and old
material and I've revamped them
just because I don't know where else to
go like at least I'm honest with you I
just don't know where else to go so I'm
taking like the greatest hits and
rewriting them over with [__] today's
2023 I'm just trying my best guys
but I know this going it I wouldn't put
myself it's like the Chappelle people
contacted me last week God bless their
hearts on the way back from New York and
they're like are you available
Saturday night to do New Year's in
Columbus
I couldn't get a flight and it was just
too [__] crazy
I called the travel agent I hate calling
travel agents you know they're like you
can just go on aaa.com whatever the [__]
are you gonna do
and uh she was like I can't get you back
till like maybe Tuesday or Wednesday and
I was like you know what it's going to
be crazy this week with the airlines
because everybody's flying back
so but hey I had it went well Jon
Stewart [__] Tammy pascitalia went
great and I'm and I let them know I go
listen if you have anything in 2023 that
you'd like me to stop in and do a show
give me in advance don't tell me two
nights before give me a [__] week or
so I know it doesn't work that way but
but I'm not for all the comedy what I'm
getting through all the
the hoopla I'm not really to that level
guys I love I can tell you yeah I'm that
guy I'm a listen it's an entertaining
show we have a great time you guys know
I always find the tangent to go off on
I'm high we have a great time we make
the videos before and after to the city
I mean this is all uh
great but I don't struggle up there but
I feel I don't feel like I did before
the pandemic is what I'm trying to say
I don't know if it's because of the
pandemic or what happened during covet
oh I don't know if it's I don't get on
stage every night like I used to it used
to be second nature for me to get on the
stage and kill it I don't know you know
I don't know what the [__] gonna
happen in 2023 I got one more show left
on the 28th of January but I got to tell
you about the 29th of January of
December
28th was a great [__] show I didn't
worry about it
I let it be very organic I made notes
leading up to the show and you know I
make my little notes and I write my
jokes or whatever but I'm not writing to
the level that I was I'm a lot of
[__] stories for the last three years
I haven't really done [__] and uh you
know I can't tell you another one of my
[__] old stories again even though
they pop up during the set of something
somebody will throw and I was going to
tell the story last week of the Segura
one-legged woman and I was like I don't
want to say it not to mention my wife
was in the audience she don't want to
hear that [__] joke but the show was
Sensational uh lee was [__] great
even though he had taken 200 milligrams
Tara was [__] tremendous uh Eleanor
is becoming a [__] Powerhouse
of a comedian guys I don't know what
Kerrigan is not [__] around up there
she took that Philadelphia work ethic
and that Philadelphia blue collar
and she's learned how to transform it on
stage and it is phenomenal guys all the
women that went I had 16 girls there
16 women came with my wife that night
total it was 16. I'm sorry
my wife had
the best birthday of her life
and I was so happy that I was a part of
it for the last 22 years guys I'm a dud
I hate my birthday you know what I'm
saying like you know when your birthday
comes like what am I gonna do I'm one of
those idiots and uh
every year it's the same [__] I take her
out to dinner
and I give her some [__] uh piece of
stupid [__] jewelry
she wears twice a year and we come home
that's our birthday
and my birthday is even worse I mean we
don't do that you know by uh
so this year her birthday found night of
that show and these girls went all out I
mean they rented a limo they went to
dinner with Carmines in the city they
walked to the show they got [__]
hammered some of them were smoking in
the back eating Edibles jumping up and
down
it was great to see my wife having a
great time and the pressure was off me I
didn't give my wife a present they gave
her a [__] card that's it because the
pressure was off me that's the hardest
thing in the world when you have to buy
something for somebody on the 24th
of December and he got turned right back
around in 20 [__] eighth for their
birthday that sucks guys you don't know
how hard you try he he can't it's not
like a secondary gift like I usually buy
my wife like a couple nice gifts and
then a couple small ones right
and you put them in your stocking a
notebook whatever and then you know but
for Christmas and and birthday you can't
give them secondary type gifts I can't
throw up their underwear I Gotta Throw
Some main [__] so
it's uh it's rough but this year the
show is great I mean the energy in the
room uh Catherine Narducci was there uh
Tara came one of my dear friends was
there I grew up with and one of them
said the same thing to me days later
they were like we've been through a lot
of shows but that show was primarily
really [__] special
the audience is all in my wife was
crying
some of the women were crying on the
side when I got on stage because
of the love in the room I mean I was
watching Lee and I couldn't believe the
love he was getting and Tara and you
know and it was just people having a
great time and that's what a comedy
Show's supposed to be guys
you know you could add the lights and
the DJs and you could jump up and down
but if the material and the love aren't
there
you got nothing in that room I've been
into I've been into
great places to perform and
I think people are just so excited to be
there they forget about what they're
there for
so when you're part of something like
that yeah listen I've been doing comedy
for 30.
and if I had a name and hundreds of
shows I I've been involved in like a
thousand shows like that where it's not
about the comedy people are just so
[__] energetic to be out you know
best best week of the year I always tell
people is the week after Christmas
and I'll tell you that the business side
of it the money side of it is great
people want to go out people are dying
to give you money to make them laugh
when you're a comic it's it's surreal
what happens on the 26th 27 28th and
29th of the month and then of course you
got New Year's you got some people call
amateur out listen
you know but comedy entertainment
[__] the 26 people can't wait to get
the [__] out I don't know what it is you
see the difference in the attitude it's
like the night before Thanksgiving I
love performing on that night I used to
perform an Irvine every year
I gotta tell you something guys I used
to sell it out
I used to make good money on that night
two shows but
shows was so goddamn bad
the shows were so goddamn bad looking
back at them
listen man
Irvine used to be 45 minutes from Studio
City
that day on Thanksgiving Day it takes
you two and a half hours
you know how many times Lee and I were
stuck in bumping a bumper traffic or
headed to Irvine
I did the Thanksgiving maybe six or
seven years in a row and I gotta be
honest with you looking back at them I
hated every one of those [__] shows
from the first year when I ate the
[__] homie Burger and I got sick on
New Year's on Thanksgiving the [__]
what's those Japanese burgers the why
there's a chain like and then they used
to cook at The Improv I ate one night I
don't know if I think it was [__] bat
beef or some [__] because I was sick but
that's not the situation here the
situation was that those shows used to
suck
Irvine's like in the middle of the place
they come to see me to stare at me they
wouldn't laugh Irvine's really weak and
I and I had great shows in Irvine I'm
just talking about the night before
Thanksgiving there was a couple clubs I
couldn't [__] conquer if I wanted to
in Orange County just for particular
reasons it became a mental thing then I
started rock and roll and I steamrolled
past the mental thing but Irvine the
night before Thanksgiving I'd do it
every year and every year on the drive
home I would giggle and how it was just
a show
it was just a nun
it felt like a non-committal show like
they came to watch me I performed they
left and I left
there was nothing else there so it was
like this sucks so don't get me wrong
there's places that you go to that the
energy is just off the money's good the
food is good they laughed they laughed
it's not like you died I'm not saying
anything about that that you died on
stage or anything they just
Just Energy wasn't right in the room
that was completely opposite Wednesday
night at uh the Sony Hall I mean so if
you were there you came out for a great
show there was a couple patreon guys
there my man Rick was there he came back
there with his son he gave me a couple
[__] uh
police cards you know when you get
pulled over you give it to them and [__]
great great people great night great
venue this is my last one I don't know
if I'm going to continue to do it or
when I might have to take February off
for the book to do the audiobook or
March I'm we're gonna you know we're
going into the new year this year this
year is a week of [__] phone calls
because uh we didn't do [__] last week
and even like I usually do this on
Monday Monday was a [__] dead day
Sunday I was gonna get behind no podcast
Mike for Monday Monday nobody was out
there nobody was [__] out there
Monday morning I went to breakfast there
was nobody out there there was no
traffic so it was like even my daughter
it's hard to even like you look at your
kids okay my daughter doesn't drink my
daughter's a smoke pot my daughter
doesn't take ecstasy you know what I'm
saying she doesn't do any of that [__]
she's a 10 year old little girl
you have to see her you had to see her
Monday and Sunday New Year's Day New
Year's day she was gone
she had a sleepover New Year's night the
night before that we went to a [__]
party
you know she played basketball Thursday
or something it was [__] like we were
we they went to some basketball facility
because it's been 60 [__] degrees for
you people don't know it it's been 60
[__] degrees the other day some
girl on Facebook just trying to be a
jerk off and it's like how'd you how do
you enjoy moving to Jersey are you
freezing your ass off ready to come back
to Canada and I'm like [__] it's 60
degrees you're getting rain out there so
today's the wrong day for you to be
making fun of me stupid [__] is it
cold out the [__] just wrong with you 60
[__] degrees
but looking at my daughter about four
o'clock New Year's Day I could tell she
was damaged goods
she was damaged goods I asked her what
time she went to sleep New Year's Eve
but I went to sleep about one they slept
till about nine
so but I could just tell from just and
not drinking and not smoking and not you
know we didn't go to New York City we
didn't do any of that crazy stuff in the
car it was such a concentration of
people and kids and you know [__] for
five or six days she just shot I asked
her you want to go to school Monday and
she's like not a million [__] years
she goes I'll be ready by Tuesday but
Monday not even [__] close just
looking at them
to let you know how taxing the holidays
are on you like that [__] it gets
Christmas day you're like
when does this tree go down you're like
yeah six more [__] days look at
this goddamn tree and it's so weird
because it's like you're 50 recovered
after the 25th like the 26th you feel
like half your body's back to normal but
you still feel like okay I got one more
week of this New Year's to jump up and
down
and then New Year's comes and you're
like when that [__] ball drops you
are so [__] happy you're like thank
God and I tried watching that David
what's that called Dick Clark thing oh
my God guys New Edition what has
happened
to our society
and I didn't sit there like regular
Americans and watch it and jump up and
down I was watching them between the
Georgia game and just to see
but I flicked back one time and I heard
this song by Duran Duran I'm like look
at these guys singing Duran Duran songs
who the [__] are these
and all of a sudden the camera panned
them and I'm like wait a second
that is Duran Duran Simon Labon is not
looking too good these days I ain't
looking too good either but but I wasn't
looking good from the beginning look
when you're ugly in the beginning and
you get older you get uglier but when
you're good looking at the beginning you
got ugly that's real [__] ugly
because for me I was ugly all along but
from Simon Lebon who's like a [__]
heartthrob he's out there singing
cocaine and white lines and Hungry Like
the Wolf when that came a panned on to
him and I saw that LeBron had a bigger
gut than I did not Bueno guys and then
the other they had the other guy that I
recognized and they had a guy like with
a green tuxedo and like a red hat on
like a [__] guy was pale he had no
testosterone no vitamin D in his body
this [__] look worse than make
noise
I don't know why the [__] he was on
there they had a black chick with
Plankton on [__] hair they had people
Swap and spit the music was God awful
and then they put Wiz Khalifa up there I
saw a whiz direct from LA and I'm like
didn't even let him smoke pot they put a
hat on him that said get high or
something like that okay come on guys
come on guy but the check must be
[__] outrageous for Wiz Khalifa but
the [__] chakra of the night was
Shaggy
let me ask you a question NBC ABC
whoever did this [__] New Year's beef
Bash
I got no disrespect for Shaggy that song
that song is 80 [__] years old
so weird how they try to get YouTube
people right like YouTube kids and Tick
Tock kids and they did what they did and
then they mixed them in with like
[__]
a couple of modern acts and then they
mixed them in with like [__] real low
lacks like me like Duran Duran and
[__] Boyz II Men was a boy's coming
new edition
nah Bobby Brown is busy Bobby Brown is
in Boston making eggs so [__] uh yeah
like it was just and I'm not here to
criticize nothing everybody has their
own [__] taste but that's not the
Dick Clark Show I grew up on and when I
saw [__] immigrants making out on TV
like people from other countries did you
see that like all these tan people
swapping spit up it's like oh Dick Clark
is [__] spinning in his grave I saw
the country [__] New Year's Eve thing
a couple segments of that and that was
way better way better than [__] Dick
Clark's show the rocking one and Miley
Cyrus wasn't bad either until she
started hugging people and [__]
acting like you know she gives a [__]
then I had a switch yeah I I can't deal
with that ship at all though if you
stayed and it was a good night like I
said I stayed in I just wanted to
[__] uh
I don't know I was waiting to see if
anything like any kind of idea I asked
around I couldn't see myself in a
restaurant for New Year's with a DJ
that is just so [__] cheesy I just
did not want to bring the ball in during
[__] New Year's I don't drink on New
Year's so
you know I was telling uh
I'm happy I lived a life that was weird
and I saw some weird things
but there were some things I [__]
just learned from you know
I went to see Aerosmith
which somebody at the Nassau Coliseum
me and Mike Denny the Devil he's doing
time now North Carolina for killing his
wife
well that's what I heard I don't know if
he killed his wife he killed somebody
his grandmother it doesn't matter
me and the devil went over there and we
run in New Year's Eve there was no snow
or anything
I just remember we had done some acid
and we had done a few bumps a couple
beers I wasn't drunk or like none of
those you know New Year's Eve people
dropping eight o'clock there's puke
everywhere I had a good time at
Aerosmith what I remember from the
concert
and uh you know we drove back I think we
came over to George Washington I just
remember we went through uptown
and it must have been about 1 30 in the
morning on New Year's Eve 1980 and we're
driving through Uptown North Bergen
going downtown on Kelly Boulevard
and we just passed the 91 Street Bend
shooting down like 85th Street past uh
Roma pizza and all of my favorite pizza
there
and as we get to a bar named regs
the people the bar was closed so that's
it had to be after [__] three the bar
was closed
so sorry about that and as we pulled up
we didn't we want to kind of go into the
bar or anything we were just driving on
Kennedy Boulevard but as we pulled up at
that light at 80 whatever the street is
85th Street
there was uh
car that hit a pole
smoke was coming out of it and there was
maybe another bystander who was there to
who had gotten that we were probably
either second or third on the on the
[__] Street on County Boulevard Mike
Denny pulled over
and I remember that the car that we were
at RX7
and the car that the people were driving
was an RX-7 a Mazda any if anybody
remembers of my RX-7 it was basically a
glorified casket for two people that's
that's all it is you get head in the
[__] you get hit in the RX-7 guys
they're just burying you in the [__]
RX7 like this why should they even take
you out and put you know it's a waste of
time
so as I got out I got out of the car
because it was an accident and there was
smoke coming out of the hood of the car
and the car had gone into
a pole but it was right down the middle
of the hood like he hit it straight on
50 50 on both sides
when
I looked in the driver's side
I just saw somebody slumped over and
there was blood on the windshield when
she was blasted and stuff
but the girl that he was with was crying
I didn't know all the ages you know I
could I could be wrong 20. let's just
say 20 18 I don't know around there I
didn't know the person they were not
from North Bergen
and you know as we I got shocked by the
ambulances and the police that pulled up
while we were looking
until I get away from the scene Get Away
From The Scene we were right there guys
and they're evaluating they're pushing
everybody back like me and the other two
or three people they're pushing us back
and they're going in the car and they
you know open up the passenger side the
driver's side and I heard them say he's
gone
like he's gone I remember like it just
took the wind out of my [__] sails I
was like what the [__] he's gone
and then they tried to open up the
passenger side and that's the side that
was stuck I don't know what what you
know a car collapsed in the front
they were trying to open up the capacity
sign they couldn't get it but they had a
moonroof so the guy got on top of the
car the fire man got on top of the car
and he ripped the moon roof open and
he's yelling down or whatever and then I
remember they gave him a saw
and as he was cutting 10 minutes later
or something now it's a full [__]
accident scene
they've already yelled that he's dead
and
I'm on acid
I need this [__]
I'm on a [__] tremendous hit of
[__] acid
and it's starting like you know it's
kicking what the [__] am I telling you
it's [__] kicking so
you know I'm hearing buzzes and and
ambulances and [__] uh it was like a
joys of life but they were cutting
through the car you know you could see
the Sparks and [__] so I'm tripping and
I could hear a yell
happy New Year you bad [__]
this episode is sponsored by better help
listen it's the beginning of the year
and life could be a little overwhelming
working with a therapist can make you
more prepared to take on anything life
throws at you listen when I was confused
a few years ago I was struggling Dana
over it better help help me out better
help is therapy option that's convenient
flexible affordable and entirely online
fill out a brief questionnaire and get
matched with a licensed therapist and
switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge very easy if you want
to live a more empowered life therapy
can help you listen man like I said I
was struggling and uh she helped me with
my goals and just to identify anxiety
when it comes how to [__] get out of
it so visit betterhelp.com Diaz today
and get 10 off your first month again
that's betterhelp.com
Diaz better help we'll help you ask for
data
I could hear her yelling how how I can't
move my leg or something I don't know
exactly it was [__] for 30 years ago
40 [__] years ago
but the moral of the story
that's why Papa
don't like to do deck on New Years that
stuck with me like a cheap [__] suit
I just remember getting the car I didn't
know her
I didn't know him I was young my mother
had just died maybe two months earlier I
was in [__] hell as it was
I had just gotten over one of the worst
nights of my life maybe two nights early
and now this [__]
and I'll never forget that I made like a
like a [__] decision right there like
I'm not a drink because I'm the other
thing I remember is the fireman taking
on a bottle of vodka
uh wolf Schmidt Baka and have maybe two
inches left and they took it so they
were drinking
so with the acid and the [__] lights
and the whole [__] thing I'm like
doesn't look like I'll be [__]
partying anymore you know that was just
I had that incident and then something
happened in 83
and I was like you know what
it's not worth it because you got to pay
attention on New Year's Eve
I was even scared driving back home
it was a [__] 10 minute ride but I
was scared driving home that night not
scared like
we're just going Jesus Christ got to
keep my eyes open for some drunk [__]
sucker you know what I'm saying because
that's the thing you're scared of the
most is getting whacked by a drunk dude
or whacking somebody yourself if you're
high or something so
I got home and I was happy and that's
been the model for me like guys I even
hate going on a New Year's to do comedy
when I did come down New Year's I missed
the ice house because I would do the 7
30 show and you're oh you're in your car
at a quarter of nothing
you go to whatever party you want you go
to whatever dinner you want
I like doing New Year's early that [__]
are counting down like [__] Dick
Clark
I'm not good with the [__] countdown
I'm not good with those countdowns
although I just want to get the [__] out
of there so but I'm happy it's a new
year you know I always keep I don't know
if if my happiness is for the holidays
or if my happiness is always for the new
year no matter what position I've always
been in my life
there's always something that that's
excited you about the new year like
you're like okay my life's gonna change
this is gonna happen I'm gonna lose 80
pounds I'm gonna [__] meet a woman
you know you have all these [__]
goals you know
but it's the biggest I think the biggest
problem I made as a kid and I don't know
people make it for a fact
how I made for many years is
the mistake of thinking that
things are just going to change like
guys and I'm the king of that [__]
things are just gonna change it's a new
year don't worry about nothing your
bills are gonna go away
somebody's going to just give you a
check you know somebody's going to give
you a call
whatever you're going to meet a girl's
going to knock on your door mat naked
and it's going to come in that's what
you're thinking you know this is my year
to hit the [__] Lottery this is my
year to
win the [__] contest at work it's
always like a game of chance I didn't
like it as a game a chance I really
didn't it's so weird when I think New
Year's like uh
when I first got off Coke in 2008 was
the first New Year's that my mind looked
a little different
you know when you're when you have an
addiction or
you have some [__] uh what do they
call like a vice
you know you always think that success
is to get money that make that Vice
coming more like if you like hookers and
you know you like [__] hookers like
there's a kid on my patreon that's like
I'm eight days when I'm [__] a hooker
you know what the [__] are you talking
about guy you know what the [__] are you
talking about but it's Hey listen vices
of vices it could be Viking it could be
Xanax it could be Coke weed whatever so
the wheel like for me as a cokehead I
was like this is the year I snort more
coke than next year you know because I'm
gonna make more money than next year
than last year you know like you just
thought about all these stupid things
like it's gonna be different
is it going to be [__] different how
like
and when I that hit me like I was like
yeah New Year's is coming things are
going to change I'm gonna have a I'm
going to have a different perspective
and a different attitude
just like that
just like that it's like when you get
baptized you ever seen like when you get
baptized you think things are going to
change that day you're going to see like
adults getting baptized they put them in
the lake backwards and they hit them in
the head then they pull them up and
they're like get changed you know or
whatever pray the gay you know like when
they're gonna pray the gay away or you
know all these things that we've grown
to believe are going to happen just
because you know the power of prayer and
all this the power of prayer is great
I'm not here doubting it
but you could just pray so [__] much
before you got to do something it's got
to be active on your side for years
we've waited on the universe to just
change its course on us
we're gonna hit a lottery ticket I'm
gonna drive down the street and find the
suitcase and all my problems are gonna
be [__] gone that's that's the
Band-Aid that we've grown up thinking
that really is [__] possible and
listen I could be wrong it could be
today it's Tuesday you can [__] go
into uh go go to Yahoo and while you're
there maybe a butter roll to [__] go
what the [__] give me a picket ticket
and you hit the picket and and you won
three billion I hope I'm the first
[__] you hit me up and say go
[__] yourself I defeated the odds I'm
there with you at least throw me an
all-purpose loan but what are the odds
of that really [__] happening it's
not so we have to up our game and change
our game not much not much people think
you got to make all these [__] great
changes and I gotta stay in every night
I gotta eat Special K I gotta [__]
you know no it's not that extreme it's
like a diet like last uh Sunday night on
60 Minutes
they had a thing about diet drugs
these new synthetic Hollywood type drugs
for people who have like a little beer
belly but they're really meant for
people who are
like me people who are uh whatever the
[__] you call it obese you have obese
syndrome whatever the [__] it is
they want 1200 for these [__] shots
you know like 1200 a month to these
[__] shots they ain't cheap guys
and you know
but it's so weird to see people want to
lose weight because I was one of those
people I thought like ah I'm gonna get
big and just you know stop drinking salt
and I'm gonna lose weight and it if you
watch that show Sunday night it's the
[__] that I've always known
obesity has to do with genetics
you could eat carrot sticks every
[__] day and still be overweight a
lot of it I know a lot of you guys
saying general what are you talking
about but my point is like I have a
friend that's getting the surgery and
in their mind everybody who gets a
surgery or who goes on a diet thinks
that life is going to change
miraculously
oh it's going to change just like that
I'm going to meet the girl of my dreams
once I lose the 800 pound the fat ball
on my neck you know like you're gonna
all of a sudden and it's so weird the
expectations we have As Americans and as
humans but mostly As Americans like this
shit's just gonna
go away you know
and even with me like the last month
I've tried to lose weight and I've
succeeded I've dropped like nine pounds
but it's been the roughest [__] nine
pounds I've ever lost in my life
with the [__] uh holidays or whatever
that's not the point here the point is
that
you have to change your lifestyle
and that's whether it's a diet
you know
this year I want to make the podcast a
little stronger you know I want to do
something with a A friend of mine we're
gonna do more videos you know like more
Instagram videos
and it's basically a podcast but it's
the same it's not going to be a podcast
but it's the same result I get to
communicate to you guys let you know
what I'm doing and the whole thing the
same thing happens
when you're looking for something that
thinks when you're looking for something
that you think is going to just change
miraculously like it's 2023 everything's
going to change my problems are going to
go away no no no no no no no no no
they're probably going to go away but
you have to work at them
a little bit
just a little [__] bit I love this
time of the year I [__] love it
because it checks me
I get checked every day by myself by me
you know me guys I beat myself up every
day I'm a loser I'm a stiff I'm this and
that but this is the biggest checking I
do every year because it lets you know
what you need to do everybody thinks
just because it's a new year that
everything's going to change no
everything's going to change if you put
an effort into it how do you do that
just three little [__] things
three little [__] things you're gonna
drink more water this year
you're going to read more those are my
guys I didn't do from my goals this year
were very [__] simple
and they were all to I want to start
playing the guitar a little more I want
to be more consistent with it you know
if you play on a Monday and then play
two weeks later on a Thursday you're not
going to improve on no [__] you know
and that's what I've been doing with it
I want to put little goals did I say I
want to be in a rock band
did I say I wanted to do a concert but I
say I wanted to hang out with the Foo
Fighters and see what the news who's the
new Drummer they're looking for one I
think it's going to be Taylor's son or
the dude from Queen's son
I think
you know they're moving on now no I did
see they posted something you know and
they did it right I love them how they
react and stuff uh
you know this is what I've been thinking
about this year for the last three weeks
this is why I took off last week I
didn't want to do anything I didn't want
to do a [__] thing and every day I
just made notes just little notes on
what differences what are the little
differences I wanted in 2023
do I want to have a boat none of that
[__] you know material things don't do
dick for me
I want to be better how do I get better
do I add an extra Jiu Jitsu class do I
do I go to cryotherapy and so I can get
more recovered so I can hear the next
Jujitsu class or maybe lift weights one
extra day I'm already working out four
days a week but do I need five I don't
[__] know
but these are the things I was thinking
about how can I make the joint just a
little bit [__] better
I didn't write down my goals I wanted to
read the number one podcast I wanna I
don't give a [__] I just want to be
happy and I want you guys to be happy
and I want to give you the right amount
of content to write about the right
type of content to make this work
between us I'm not looking to [__] ad
videos or [__] beats you know uh
what's his name Bill Maher and whatever
the [__] it is guys I'm just looking to
be happy
this is one of these things that I never
every year we we [__] look at our
goals and we go all this [__] we need to
make more money this year I need to work
more this year I need to work harder
yeah I need to do all those things also
but the number one goal of this year
that I never really focused on was just
being happy being chill letting things
go by a little more you know who gives a
[__] it's like this week if this was 10
years ago me and Mike would have [__]
we would have been here New Year's Day
if you had a podcast on Monday because
we gotta go we're missing something no
we're not
they're not even in the [__] mood for
it you know when we
stopped doing uh
you know like this month in January I
think I'm just gonna do one podcast a
month until we get going you know why
[__] over bill it's not that type of
party no more and I know it's not I'm
about to turn 60. in less than two
months and that's been on my mind
a [__] lot lately
a lot first of all what a lie for years
I sweated 60. well look let's get down
to basics for years I never thought I
would make 60. okay let's let's I
thought I was gonna go and this whole
what nobody understands in my life is
that this whole [__] thing
has been I didn't expect or see any of
this coming let's start from scratch for
starters I was going to die when I was
37.
I just
since the time I'm a kid
my mother my dad died when he was 37 and
I never thought I would make him past
37. I'm like it's just not going to
happen and that's okay
you know that's how I expected my life
was such a [__] [__] show
that when I was 20 I was like I'm gonna
die at 37.
and I got to tell you something that's
okay because if this is
this is the first 20 years of my life
and they've sucked you know no family
they're struggling whatever this is what
life is the struggle
I'd rather not do this no more this is
not the life I want to live so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to party I'm
not gonna take responsibility for
anything
and I'm gonna [__] just be a bum
until I [__] die at 37.
but then 38 37
2001 2000 January 1st I woke up in El
Paso Texas and I wasn't [__] dead I
still remember where I did comedy to uh
for what was what did they call the yeah
Y2K that remember I was on stage
thinking the power was going to turn out
people gonna kick the doors in with
[__] power beams it's a new world
it's a new time that didn't [__]
happen
but if you ever heard my [__] story I
thought I was gonna die at 37.
my life began at 37.
because 37 was the age when I met my
wife Terry
37 was the age when
I kind of realized I was on to something
I went to something with the stand-up
comedy I've been doing this for nine
[__] years and
nobody realized I'm a thief yet I
haven't robbed the comedy club yet I had
a I haven't kidnapped the comedian yet I
haven't gotten into a fight with a
comedian yet
this has planned out to be an okay
[__] mission
I'll stick it out for another [__]
couple of years but that's what happened
when I was I thought I was going to die
at 30 [__] seven
so at 37 when I met my girlfriend and
she was very nice I was like I might
have a chance here
I might have a [__] chance I was
getting spotted at the store I was
starting to travel with Joe Rogan and
I'm like
this is starting to pan out and now what
23 [__] years later
I'm about to turn [__] 60 and I
thought that we would all look like
Archie Bunker
I thought that I would be in like a
stroller you know like you know like I'm
not exaggerating to you guys guys this
is you know I came when I was 20 it was
a different time of being 20 when you
guys are being 20. you know I saw a
picture of uh Heidi Fleiss is it Heidi
fly not he flies the girl who's married
to seal
pretty girl that was married to seal she
posted a picture herself two weeks ago
Heidi Klum maybe Adam Heidi Klum she's
58 years old with a [__] bikini on
did anybody see those pictures of her
been worn in a sexual way it was just to
picture her with sunglasses on a wall
with a bikini on when I went to the gym
a couple days later all the the old lady
Club was talking about those pictures
and how impressive those pictures were
because it shows you that we've [__]
come so far in 20 [__] years 25 years
you never expected look at all these
people you see on Instagram in their 60s
and 50s doing things Mick shag is going
to tour this [__] him and Keith are
gonna tour this year and they're gonna
turn 80 years old this year
when I was a kid you didn't do anything
but die at 80 years old
but die when you were 75 [__] years
old never mind going poor like Bruce
Springsteen and his bandmates
this has been [__] it's just
that I'm 60 and there's a guy that busts
my balls all the time on patreon John
Mickelson he's like you can't retire I
made some stupid jokes a couple years
ago I thought that I would just retire
and then I realized that I don't know
how [__] people retire because
there's nothing to [__] do
there's nothing to do I went to lunch
with a buddy of mine this year maybe uh
last year I'm like when are you gonna
retire from UPS and he's like why would
I this guy is my age and he works seven
days a week
from November 25th
to January like third he doesn't take a
day off I asked him when do you he gets
six weeks vacation a year and he only
takes two of them
because his wife only takes two of them
he has something to do he will not take
a week vacation off by himself because
he says it's that [__] boring and
when I thought about retiring I listened
guys I was just talking [__] I thought
that I could get like a part-time job at
Costco and put stickers on people's
orders like a regular old guy that's
never gonna [__] happen so that's
what I was talking about so it's not
gonna pan out but now thinking about it
I kind of worked like put me in the
casket
you got to work till they put you in the
listen I'm gonna turn 60 I'm walking
okay I'm losing weight I work out I
drink plenty of water God knows I get
plenty of [__] sleep lately God knows
I get plenty of [__] sleep you know
this whoop watch I'm sleep I'm getting
REM sleep now
which I never REM slept for [__] 20
[__] years and I was doing comedy
because you wake up in three hours your
body's like why why would I [__] even
indulge in that [__] when you're not
gonna wake up
so
you know I do my physicals I gotta go
for blood uh this week I'm probably
gonna go Wednesday morning and give some
blood got a heart doctor appointment on
the 10th I'm taking care of myself at
60. this is a great [__] feeling
you know Mike and I were talking about
things we're going to do with DraftKings
uh this year and everything I'm gonna be
60. I thought that I would be like
halfway [__] dead and listen don't
get me wrong guys I can't deliver for
UPS now it's like I'm gonna take a
roofing job or I can work for FedEx
Federal Express and deliver [__]
boxes and climb stairs I can't do that
either I'm not gonna lie to you about
that
but I'm happy that I'm active uh you
know I love going to Jujitsu to keep my
mind going even if it's a basic class to
learn non-bar it doesn't matter because
you're taking steps and that fights that
[__] dementia even if you're hitting
the bag you know you're working
combinations you got to remember those
combinations so that helps you a little
bit so I'm trying to do the best I can
so I see me [__] going to whatever
I'm looking at stand up this year a
little bit maybe a couple shows when I
don't [__] know I'll keep you posted
and I'm also looking at doing something
with Vic I'm looking at [__] uh
but not the book this year which I'm
[__] if anybody knows I am brutally
excited about because I get this [__]
thing off my neck this has been a
[__] this has been a nightmare for
[__] 15 years that I just want to get
off my back I just want to be able to
tell my story tell my mom's story and
move the [__] on but uh yeah I'm excited
about 2023
I got a lot of good things happening you
know uh
2022 ended the year strong I listen I
talked to all these people I answer your
messages I know a lot of these weren't
struggling this [__] holiday honest
to God I usually get horrible holiday
messages people not doing well this was
one year where people were [__]
just everybody was in a good mood man so
2023 2023 is going to be a better year
listen we could talk about it like other
people you know there's a lot going on
right now well Joey what are we gonna do
about the war you know what about the
covert that's hitting China who gives a
[__]
just be happy we're alive today we made
it to another [__] year it's [__]
Tuesday you know and that's it's going
to be an easy [__] week and I'm
excited if you're out of weed in Jersey
Stoners Club [__] Uncle Joey 10
off for Life Uncle Joey is the code 10
off for [__] life they they have some
weed in Jersey now
I forget what it's called I will post it
later on on Twitter
it's I gotta give some to Mike it's
like 60 they dip it in Ash and some
something else it looks pale it looks
like a pale Indian it just looks pale
but dog it gives you a nice little
[__] buzz so if you want to give it a
try I'll post it on my Twitter late I'm
sorry I'm not prepared like I said guys
I'm just excited about the possibilities
in 2023 I'm happy I finally got this
[__] book out I'm happy that uh we're
gonna add a different Dynamic to the
podcasting and podcasting in general and
my Instagram and
and that's what's going on that's how I
feel
and that's [__] it
um
one thing I did this year I think I'm
going to re-sign up with better help
because you always have all these
questions in the beginning of the year
like you're like
you know what should I do with goals
this that and like I say in the pitch
for it sometimes you need somebody to
help you with a decision you know I went
with better help last year
or the two years ago when I was
struggling with the [__] uh with the
when I was withdrawing and all that just
to get my thoughts in order guys it's
always there for you and if you don't
want to go on therapy you got your best
friend to bounce it off their [__]
walls but
this is it it's life it's 2023 I'm
[__] excited we're here another year
like I said we're only putting out one
podcast this week
and uh we'll keep you [__] uh
we'll let you know what's cracking
that's it and that's that you bad
[__] have a great day and I'll
be back next Monday the 9th Tip Top
Magoo ready to go love you and here's a
word from our sponsors
all right it's the kick of the new year
thank you thank you for supporting and
for loving we won't do another one until
next Monday just to give you a [__]
chance to come out of your coma like Rip
Van Winkle anyway the joint is brought
to you by Mint mobile why are you still
paying insane amounts of money for every
month for your phone bill right now when
you switch to Mint mobile you'll get
unlimited plan for 50 off order from
home and save with phone plans starting
at just 15 a month hurry because this
deal ends January 15th you're gonna buy
any three month plan and get three more
months free even on their unlimited plan
all moment Mobile plans are come with
unlimited talks and tax high-speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5G
Network by any three month plan and get
three more months free by going to
mintmobile.com Joey again that's
mintmobile.com Joey cut your wireless
bill to 50 15 bucks a month at Hunt
mintmobile.com Joey all friends January
15th the joint is also brought to you by
freeze pipe listen it's time to invest
in yourself and get the best tools for
the job your job is like my job to smoke
dope with three hands and freeze pipe is
here to make sure you got the best tools
to get you high all the way to 2024.
just freeze it pack it and rip that
[__] the smoke passes through
the Frozen part cooling down the smoke
as you inhale listen I had a blast at
this thing over the holidays it didn't
snow but I froze that pipe and I saw the
devil every [__] day The 12 Days of
Christmas free pipe cools down the Smoke
by 100 degrees makes your lungs feel
[__] tremendous and your lungs will
thank you so your uncle Joey's taking
care of you on the first Tuesday of the
year with freezepipe.com you got that
Christmas money let's do this [__] I'm
Gonna Save You 10 off on a bun pipe a
bubbler today that's thefreeze pipe.com
pressing code Diaz Diaz to say ten
percent the joint is also brought to you
by listen we're starting off the year
you don't want to bring your [__]
headaches into this year contact
betterhelp.com you like Joy why do I
talk to you what do I need
betterhelp.com because they're an online
therapy service that's convenient
flexible and affordable you can fill out
a brief questionnaire get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapists
anytime but no additional charge it's
that easy listen when I was stuck Dana
helped me over at uh better help and she
did a great job because here I am Tip
Top [__] the goo so if you want
to live a more empowered life therapy
can get you there visit betterhelp.com
Diaz again
betterhelp.com Diaz and I'm Gonna Get
You 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com slash Diaz I want to
thank better help freeze pipe and mint
mobile and I want to thank you guys for
always having our back we're gonna have
a great thing for you in 2023 so thank
you for your support and love and I'll
see you [__] next Sunday
morning Monday morning Tip Top Magoo
stay black Uncle Joey loves you
thank you
foreign